it is 3 p.m on saturday it's been two
whole weeks since my last youtube video
and my goal for the last seven days was
to put together a new video for you guys
to post
tomorrow sunday so that i could try to
be more consistent
i've spent the last two weeks like in
montana hiking backpacking i'm back in
washington now there was like a
massive heat wave and it's still really
hot out actually
but of course i decided right now
when i have like nine hours to actually
work on the video
that it's a great time to tear apart my
van and clean it from
top to bottom so yeah uh
welcome to my life here we go actual
footage
of my van right now
20 minutes ago i was sitting at my
computer working and then i just got
bored i guess
and now here we are
such a mess here's another angle for
anyone out there that thinks my van
always looks clean truthfully it
normally does
but sometimes i just go on cleaning
rampages and it turns into
a complete disaster
[Music]
and just like that two more weeks have
gone by and it's now been a whole month
since my last post
i have four weeks of footage to sift
through and it makes me wonder
where does all the time go since i've
been out on the road
i've struggled to get back into the
swing of things between work and the
road and hiking
and making time for family and friends
and catching up on errands and deadlines
and the usual van chores
the days just kind of disappear but
whenever i sit down to patch it all
together and attempt to create a video
i'm reminded of all the memories made
and all the roads traveled
so even though i'm clearly really bad at
consistently documenting and sharing
life as it happens
i'll keep trying because a lot of these
places are just too beautiful not to
[Music]
share
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the plan was montana for at least a few
more weeks every summer i'd be lined for
the washington cascades and this year i
wanted to spend more time in idaho and
montana before heading west
going to the sun road was finally open
and the weather was pretty perfect
nate and i met up with some friends from
washington and we all spent a few days
hanging out and hiking around the park
[Music]
that's great they were just kind of uh
they were odd there's a there's a
huckleberry cafe right
[Music]
catching up with friends i realized that
i hadn't actually been back to
washington since
september of last year or nine months
ago
which is crazy to think about when you
call place home and end up leaving
unintentionally for so long
in some ways life moves fast on the road
but
day to day it feels slow if you ask me
where i was and
who i was with one week ago i would
literally have to check my calendar
but if you asked me when i was last home
i would want to say just a few months
ago
time is funny like that it just kind of
fades when you're on the road
huckleberry jam
[Music]
[Music]
ingredients i mean that's good too i
thought
[Music]
very nice family dinner camping in the
rain
green time this is what it's all about
rain or shine family meal
dinner is delicious yeah this is really
amazing
so our friends just left but we're
booking another night at the campsite
to just relax and nate just made
[Music]
breakfast
after some time on the east side nate
and i drove to whitefish montana to meet
up with our friends alex and eric for a
multi-night trek in glacier back country
this was my first overnight of the
season and my first tent camping
experience in grizzly country
so here is what packing for a
backpacking trip in the van looks like
it's thunderstorming outside so i have
the bike inside
all my stuff is just strewn everywhere
i'm just hoping i don't forget anything
important so
it's kind of like a storage unit in here
right now
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
so
it's about 3 p.m so we're making good
time
and yeah today's a 14 mile day
was
it's pretty big
we just saw our first black pair run up
through there
mile 11. oh
so we are hanging our bear bags because
we're in grizzly country
and we can't take any of our food or
toiletries
near the campsite
that sounds freaking roasting
we're improvising here because the
string was stretched out there we go
nice nice
oh you sleep that way i guess it's like
a square
you're going to be climbing all over
pretty nice campsite there's only three
campsites in this whole place
um they're these little tiny winged uh
blood sucking
birds called mosquitoes and um
yeah this helps a little bit i have one
too
alex is unbothered by bugs you don't
have one either
you're just toughing it out i guess huh
oh yeah i mean
i'm still being eaten alive we are
cooking up dinner
up the jetboil and we're gonna have a
community dinner
in this little eating space we have to
eat in this specific spot
because of grizzly bears so we can't eat
anything
near the campsite we have to eat it all
here
gourmet mac and cheese
oh
[Laughter]
are you telling me
here we have the camp bathroom this cute
little outhouse in the middle of nowhere
[Music]
[Music]
feels good now actually all right we're
all packed up heading down to the lake
got our stretches in
i wish the other spot had
[Applause]
we are setting up camp camp
check out this little path that goes
down to the water
and here's the toilet for this campsite
another outhouse and the most scenic
place
we're making dinner before sunset
i'm heading back to camp to grab
this water bottle
which is collapsible when it's empty but
has a filter at the top
so i can just fill it up in the lake
and then drink it right out of the
bottle or squeeze it into a nalgene
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is our last night out here and it's
still bright outside
but it's like 10 p.m
[Applause]
so
busting out the medical supplies do you
have like got blisters
we're pumped up so it's 8 30 in the
morning we woke up at five
to shoot sunrise then we made breakfast
and coffee
and say goodbye to everyone else in camp
now we're heading out at 8 30.
we have a nine mile day and it's
supposed to be pretty hot so
it's going to be a workout
[Applause]
this is bear grass
[Music]
this is the last quarter of a mile
and we are so spent it's just really hot
outside
we've been hiking uphill
all right we made it back how we feeling
exhausted
first order of business is removing
these boots
[Music]
you